hallo mein name ist luca und ich mag
youtube aber es gibt auch einige sachen
die ich an youtube nicht so mag und da
ich wollte noch kein video vorproduziert
habe dachte ich mir ich in sachen hier
einfach mal zehn verschiedene sachen die
ich an youtube com ich war beim friseur
ich bin ich weiß nicht ob ich damit
zufrieden sein soll das ist so mega kurz
an den seiten und
wir fangen an mit sache nummer 1 die
verarbeitungszeit ich denke als otto
normal zuschauer weiß man das nicht so
aber wenn man selber youtube-videos
hochlädt und diese auch öffentlich
direkt freischalten film dauert der
upload vielleicht bei einer normalen
internetleitung so eine halbe stunde und
die verarbeitung dort an ca fünf tage
man sitzt da wirklich wählten video aus
legt das hoch und youtube braucht
erstmal 1000 jahre um dieses video zu
verarbeiten verarbeiten heißt das video
anschaut machen also nicht nur auf 144 p
freizuschalten sondern dann wirklich auf
720p hd und da letztlich youtube
irgendwie immer sehr viel zeit sache
nummer zwei die ich an youtube hast du
beziehungsweise an der plattform an sich
und den nutzern ist einfach dieses ein
video ist eine minute online das video
geht zehn minuten und jemand schreibt
nach zehn sekunden war geiles video voll
cool du kannst es nicht gesehen haben
ich bin ein mensch ich möchte lieber in
den kommentaren stehen haben kommentare
die nach dem anschauen des kompletten
videos geschrieben wurden wo dann drin
steht hey du könntest was das besser
machen und das hat mir nicht so gut
gefallen anstatt nach fünf sekunden aber
auch folgendes video richtig tierisch
alles das ist einfach eine liebende
kritik sohn etwa drittens das kanal
design weiß nicht wie lange ihr alle
schon bei youtube mit dabei im bilde sei
die cvp aber damals so vor 34 jahren war
das kanal design so dass es bei jedem
anders war man konnte sagen welche
elemente angezeigt werden wo der player
ist wo die kommentare stehen und auch
einfach mal konnte den kompletten
hintergrund bestimmen mittlerweile hat
man nur noch diesen kleinen banner der
rest ist einfach grau und weiß das ist
man kann nichts mehr individualisieren
die vierte sah ich habe übrigens immer
noch überall wunden von diesem crash
ball ding das da das ist überall ich
habe überall das
da hat egal total um passende werbung
damals war es noch viel krasser damals
liegt dann einfach von meinen videos du
auf einmal werbung für viagra oder für
katzenfutter mittlerweile ist es aber es
hat sich eigentlich nicht verbessert ich
letztes du auch so ein video von
irgendeiner hübschen englischen beauty
bloggerin kommt davor so eine werbung
für dicke alte rentner und die
krankenversicherungen denke ich mir auch
so alles klar wenn ich so was sehen
ich weine einfach ich fange einfach an
die fünfte sache sind diese ich hasse
alles kommentarschreiber also einfach
leute die kommentare schreiben und nur
negativ sind irgendwie immer was zu
meckern haben total unzufrieden mit dem
eigenen leben sind oder einfach nur
menschen eher hassen und einfach sich an
allen irgendwie an irgendwas rächen
wollen und einfach alle irgendwie
runterziehen wollen so bestimmungen
verbreiten die braucht man auch nicht
dass das bringt mich außer müssen auch
von youtube dieser ganze hass einfach 6
und sicherte konkreter übels das spaß
dieser typ alter richtige missglückte
sache ist wieder so eine sache wo
wahrscheinlich viele leute meiner
meinung nicht übereinstimmen werden weil
meine meinung immer so ein bisschen von
einer anderen galaxie galaxie ist in
etwa man kann auf youtube
megaerfolgreich werden oder sich auch
nur ansatzweise mühe mit dem videos zu
geben das ist natürlich einerseits ganz
cool das ist dieses projekt gibt und hey
ich kenne wie ein größeres gemacht mit
dem videos und dann werde ich
erfolgreich oder ich mache einfach eine
scheiße und irgendwie feiern das
trotzdem leute aber für die leute die
hier wirklich an einem video 2 34
stunden sitzen ist es schon sehr
ernüchternd ich sehe dann beispielsweise
immer so kanäle die
die total wenig in relativ wenig
abonnenten haben aber so unglaublich
geil in kontakt machen da gibt es
beispielsweise tim kellner josh cohen
ich verlinke ihr euch einfach mal unten
die machen übelsten konnten aber einfach
viel zu wenig abonnenten dafür im
gegensatz dazu gibt es dann wieder
andere die 4 millionen abonnenten haben
wo ich mir denke jedes video von dir ist
vielleicht im schnitt zwei minuten und
in der aufnahme eine viertelstunde und
dann dass ich das verstehe ich nicht so
ganz das bin ich halt dementsprechend
auch so cool weil die mehr weil bei
vimeo sind nur wirklich so kreative
sachen und da werden doch nur sachen
erfolgreich die wirklich vom schnitt
super sind von der message to power auf
youtube kann einfach jeder rennen das
hochladen und milliarden klicks bekommen
die achte sache es gibt keine offizielle
später an den offline funktion fürs
handy natürlich gibt es diese später an
den playlist wenn man das hinzufügen
kann
aber ich wünsche mir so was wie so einen
offiziellen youtube downloader also
nicht dass man sich die videos
downloaden kann sondern dass man wie bei
irgendwelchen streaming portalen dass
man auswählen kann ok das video und dann
speichert er das für 24 stunden auf dem
handy so dass man wenn man vom vom
flieger sitzt oder so und man fliegt
gegen die acht stellen dass man sich
vorher noch mal so ein paar sachen bei
youtube quasi speichern mit dem
herunterladen kann und sich die dann
anschauen kann das vermisse ich so ein
bisschen an youtube das ist jetzt nicht
wirklich was was ich an der plattform
haste aber so was wünsche ich mir schon
seit jahren neun leute die in nahezu
jedem fall irgendwelche tippen oder
halbnackte frauen zeigen obwohl es nicht
ansatzweise was mit dem video zu tun
hatte ich mein okay ich habe es auch
schon 23 mal gemacht aber auch wirklich
nur wenn in dem video auch darum ging
die beispielsweise bei dem bis simulator
da hab ich halt die person rausgenommen
aus dem spiel die halb nackt war weil
sie in dem spiel zu sehen war wenn ich
dann allerdings youtuber sehe von jedem
zweiten video nahezu ihnen nackte frau
drin ist dann klicke ich da draußen dann
ist keinmal davon überhaupt nur die rede
dann ist es eigentlich wirklich in
strike das ist eine sache die ich übelst
dieses sammler bombing mit total
dummen sachen also es ist dafür gibt für
mich unterschied zwischen damit der
kreativität wo man irgendwas nimmt was
zum video dazu gehört oder einfach
packen tippen rein und kassieren klicks
zehntes und die letzte sache die mich an
youtube richtig aufregt diese leute die
schreiben hey cooles video schaut doch
auch bei mir vorbei nein nein nein ich
nehme ich schaue ich bei dir vorbei ich
bin der ansicht dass man auf youtube
auch noch erfolgreich werden kann wenn
man einfach guten content macht fall
wenn man die ganze zeit unter videos von
anderen youtube an schreibt hey shop bei
mir vorbei dann kennt euch zwar jeder
aber einfach nur mit dem hinterkopf
gedanken der ist doch der der immer
kommentiert mit seiner werbung also man
kann erfolgreich werden ohne dass die
ganze zeit werbung machen zu müssen ich
habe damals als ich angefangen hat mit
youtube muss ich ehrlich gesagt zu geben
auch unter einige videos geschrieben hey
schaut doch bei mir vorbei allerdings
hat mich und ist mit einem schnell
aufgefallen sollten so möchte ich
eigentlich keinen erfolg haben dann hab
ich einfach nur bei den videos gegeben
und habe das gemacht worauf ich spaß
hatte und wenn ihr youtube macht weil
ihr spaß dann habt dann ist es kann es
euch doch eigentlich scheißegal sein wie
viele leute euch abonniert haben oder
dann müsst ihr habt es doch nicht nötig
werbung zu machen also das verstehe ich
immer nie ja das war sache nummer 10
denkt ihr in den punkten genauso oder
was stört euch an youtube scheiße man
die kommentare ich mich stört bestimmt
noch viel viel mehr daran aber das fällt
einem einfach auf anhieb das nicht achim
und sonst würde ich sagen sehen wir uns
in einem nächsten video wieder